From Kal-El to Weapon X, some fans are fan-casting
the future of their favorite actor.
While "Man of Steel" was a divisive film,
many would agree that Henry Cavill made for
an excellent Superman.
Not only did he look great in the famous costume,
he also seemed to embody the character perfectly.
As a result, fans have begged to see more
of Cavill as Superman.
He's popped up in other projects since, like
"Batman v. Superman: Dawn of Justice" and
"Justice League," but he's not had the chance
to lead another solo project yet.
Since "Man of Steel" came out in 2013, Warner
Bros. has been silent regarding whether we'll
see Cavill suit up as the Last Son of Krypton
ever again.
Even when Superman appeared in the final episode
of "Peacemaker" Season 1, a different actor
slipped into Cavill's iconic suit, and his
face was never shown.
And when Superman briefly appeared in "Shazam!,"
Cavill was nowhere in sight, either.
There's a good chance we'll never see Cavill
as the Man of Steel ever again, but it's undeniable
that the actor is immensely talented.
In fact, many fans have been left wondering
if Cavill might jump ship to Marvel.
Some have even speculated that he could appear
as Captain Britain at some point in the future.
Plus, one artist has imagined what the actor
could look like as one of the most iconic
characters in all of Marvel Comics, and that's
Wolverine.
For years, Hugh Jackman was Wolverine.
The "X-Men" franchise went through various
iterations, but the one constant was that
you could always expect Jackman to show up
and lay down the hurt.
Now that Disney owns 20th Century Studios,
fans are eagerly awaiting an announcement
about when we'll see a new Wolverine actor
rise up and take the reins.
There's a lot of talk about who could feasibly
take on such an iconic role, and Henry Cavill's
name comes up from time to time.
Instagram artist @royy_ledger has even taken
it upon themselves to envision what Cavill
could theoretically look like in the role,
and the result is pretty epic.
Whereas Jackman's Wolverine was rough but
reasonably put together, Ledger's version
is positively feral, sporting the character's
iconic sideburns from the comics, as well
as an incredible mask that Jackman didn't
wear during his run.
It certainly seems to have won over fans as
plenty of people have commented, voicing their
support for the artwork.
For instance, one fan enthused,
"Definitely the BEST fan art out there ever
since this rumor came out."
"Tough image to shake."
Still, others think Cavill would be better
suited for a different mutant, with one fan
bluntly writing,
"Nope way [too] tall, and he's better for
cyclops I think."
Regardless of his next role, it's clear that
most fans just want to see Cavill appear in
another superhero property, sooner rather
than later.
It may be a while until we get another Wolverine
introduced on film.
Marvel Studios has yet to announce any upcoming
"X-Men" projects, despite having the rights
to the characters.
There's no doubt that when Wolverine's time
comes, it will be one of the most hotly sought-after
roles in Hollywood.
The question then becomes is Cavill the right
actor for the job?
Whether Wolverine makes his debut in a movie
or a Disney+ original series, there are plenty
of qualities Cavill could bring to the part
that make him an ideal choice.
For starters, he's an incredible actor, as
evidenced by a litany of eclectic parts in
the likes of "The Witcher" and "Mission: Impossible
- Fallout."
Plus, Cavill has experience playing both good
guys and bad guys, so he could embody both
the heroic and antiheroic qualities of the
character.
"Be their hero.
Be their monument.
Be their angel.
Be anything they need you to be."
Whether or not Cavill would be a good fit
for the role really depends on what iteration
of Wolverine the MCU goes with.
In the comics, Wolverine is supposed to be
around 5'2" or 5'3".
Henry Cavill stands at 6'1", so he's quite
a bit taller than the character.
Granted, Hugh Jackman was also taller than
Wolverine's suggested height, but the MCU
might want to make their next adaptation more
accurate to the comics.
There's also the question of whether or not
Cavill would have time to join the MCU in
such a major capacity with his prominent role
in Netflix's "The Witcher."
Only time will tell, but there's no doubt
that the MCU would benefit greatly from Cavill's
presence.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superhero movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.